cinquante ans avant jésus-christ après
avoir conquis la gaule l'egypte et
l'espagne
césar porte le nom de rome jusqu'à sept
îles appelées britannia incroyable moi
je conviens que j'ai la côte avec les
dieux je me demande s'il ne pourra
résister éternellement
il existe pourtant un village qui a
réussi cet exploit
bon nous durix et le matin on se lève
toi la campagne web moi j'en doutais l
utc leur local en se couchant monde en
foutez moi la paix libéraux
je vous présente jolitorax enchanté ce
coup on nous la mpt obélix souhaitons
vraiment hâte
ils ont des roms a tout d'un flat bas on
sera vite revenu tu sais allant de
délits dont on m'avait dit que toutes
les bretons étaient moches mais en salle
mb bien c'est vrai qu'elle est au lycée
saint quentinois tu vois vraiment bien
la pression je vais plaît pas j'ai
vraiment lui permit ce machin eu un
petit cadeau serait toujours plaisir et
gaulois débarqué clandestinement avec
une arme secrète dans un tournoi axe
allant de tout faire n'est-il pas mais
chérie tu as fait un peu beaucoup
engageant des mercenaires les normands
qui ont cette particularité ne pas
reconnaître at her
ceux-là
copé
c'est une bonne situation pour vous je
vous assure que ça m'intéresse vraiment
c'est parce qu'on a rarement l'occasion
de rencontrer un bourreau dans sa vie et
c'est vrai quand ça arrive ce soit la
dernière fois